hey guys
emmy are you live boy
what
i'm live
oh go fight live
we doing it doing it
we doing it live doing it live
boom
look at that little rocket in the
background
rocket what you doing
what you doing rocket
[Music]
ryan what is up
hey mr anderson are you back on a on a
computer
did a notification go out
mr anderson did you get a notification
what's up malik the king what's up adam
studios android games
tanish midnight danny
hey mighty thor my voice is a little
weak today guys sorry i have to put up
with uh
a weak voice
i think my notification went out
rude
i didn't get one rude
thanks penguin god appreciate rocket
hi
what you doing
what you doing
what are you doing come here
oh
say hi no don't scratch me hi
oh say hi
hi say hi to everybody
you fatty
[Music]
you say hi
everyone say hi to rocket
she says hi
you got it you're all right
good girl
i just got a notification there we go
can't hear me properly hello
hello hello yeah she's she's a big cat
rainbow hunter
yeah she's the greatest cat in the world
though she's she's awesome
she's a really great cat
uh
let's pull up the disney plus
how's everyone doing tonight
what is going on hey jeff
thanks for super chat yeah thor
yeah
that's funny you pull up disney plus and
it's like oh thor collection
but yeah oof can't wait to uh
i can't wait to hear what everyone
thinks of thor
because that's going to be sweet
doors
i really i really love that movie
it's a pretty great movie
uh
cool
everything looks okay
what do we think is gonna happen here
for miss marvel how many episodes are
left uh dose two
two
two two two two two
two this is the fifth one um and there's
a final one and
i'm wondering uh i'm wondering which
direction this is gonna go um
you know um
there's a lot of different ways they
could take this
i'm a little worried
who knows
you also wonder when like captain
marvel's gonna show up i'm still
thinking it's gonna be a post-credits
scene
that's just still what i think
but uh
you never know you never know never know
never know
um mr anderson how is
my mic can you hear me all
your right is good okay so uh for the
people who say the sound is off maybe
there's some settings you'll need to
adjust
stranger things yes
yes
uh
people always ask me to rate thor one
out of ten
i can't just because
i need to see it again
and
i hate kind of uh
rating it before i see it
you know
only once uh especially at a premiere
where things like really really big and
really really exciting um
mike guys my sound sounds fine i pulled
it up on my phone
sounds fine got a few people in the chat
said it's fine hey you were born in
karachi sure as that's pretty cool
you can relate to this then okay
oh yeah
cool
all right
best predictions for tonight what are
what are we thinking are the best
predictions for tonight i want to see
him i have so much cat hair on me now i
want to see him in the chat below what
what do we think
ale russell what up
miss marvel has been just cruise do you
think it's been five but yeah there's no
avengers 5 footage out there y'all
that's all from the disney cruise like
no avengers five
no
um
if we haven't heard it that would be
like saying like there's fantastic four
footage up there but it's really from
multiverse of madness like
um
yeah they're we're not gonna
get any of that footage before
the project has even announced right so
we don't even have
an avengers 5 announced yet so like
um
you know you're not gonna you're not
gonna see any footage for it tonight hey
sue
uh
thor is out in south korea right now but
uh you haven't seen it yet go see it
it's so good
it's so good
i don't know what that means
not sure what that means
you think miss marvel's gonna get
decapitated that's dark that took a dark
turn real quick
what up bob the builder bob the builder
in the chat
going so
i think they're going
so origin
origin
uh i'm good tanza
voice is a little weak today but that's
that's a
far shot predictions for episode five
um well we talked about this a little
bit at the end oh sorry
a little out of focus
good okay
we talked about this a little bit at the
end of episode four
uh after i
i
will i would think it was cool i'm not
i'm not haven't decided if i think this
is what's actually gonna happen but i
think it would be cool if
kamala is like back in time somehow
and she's the one who leaves the trail
of stars
for her grandmother
i think that would be really cool
um so
she's at partition right now
um
well i'm moving the camera my bed she's
at partition right now and i
she's in like you know
obviously like a different realm
different
part of space like
so i i wouldn't be surprised if she's
actually like you know somewhat time
traveling
and she sees her grandmother and she's
sitting there like
it's almost like a harry potter thing
right where he's like oh my dad came and
and saved us and then at the end he's
looking for his dad and he's like wait
my dad will come my dad will come and
then he realizes like oh no
he's not coming i have to do it he was
like oh it was me the entire time right
like i was the one who saved me
almost kind of like one of those things
except you know instead of
it actually you know grandma doesn't say
the grandmother but she's heard this
story you know her whole entire life
and uh as it turns out it was her the
entire time there was actually like a
part of that story who saved her
grandmother i think that would be cool
but i also think
that
i i
i think kamala's great grandmother we
have to explore that story right i mean
they have to explore that because
they're talking about how her
grandmother this entire time
was like
this
like a bad person like a disgrace to so
much cat hair like a disgrace to uh her
family
and uh and how
they had to move her her mom moved
across the world you know to
to escape that i think
that's gonna all be revealed to where
it's like her grandma was actually like
a good you know person
i hope
hope hope hope pope
uh can you please make marvel fan films
david uh russell uh i've thought about
it and i i would love to
it cost a lot of money
and there's a lot
of like legal hoops you have to go
through and like i'm sure if i talk to
disney since i'm tight with them they
would say yes
but it's still a lot
um it's a lot of money
and you're not allowed to make money off
it which i don't care that's not why i
would do it um
uh there's just so it's i've looked into
it um
and it's just really really hard you
need so
you need a cinematographer
an editor you know um director actor
like there's so much produce you know
producers there's just so much that goes
into it and it's just so much money that
it's just uh
it's really hard but hopefully
eventually i may i can make one
yeah
you want to see howard the duck and
she-hulk hero 702
i mean we've already seen him in the mcu
we could definitely pop up uh you know
in other places
uh i did see the quantum corner at
disney cruise i saw you know the video
and stuff
oh really
really aj okay you can get me with your
your paint
yes uh
so we're gonna make a fan film all in
paint apparently
uh
my buddy aj deputy 1024 is gonna um
he's gonna do it all he's gonna edit it
all on everything there we go we got it
there we go there we go
uh eight minutes tilts out uh thor
forward doctor strange two thor four
brandon richardson's uh it's not even
like a question in my mind like i don't
even have to think about it
it's like right away thor for it
the world and thunder all day
i think i just got here um yeah
miss marvel's definitely like appealing
to that younger audience for sure for
sure
just trying to see namor i mean
well kind of forever even tina cuerta
basically confirmed that today or
yesterday sometime he posted
a picture of uh
uh mermaid man from spongebob
kind of like tease you know and i mean
like kind of teasing that he's you know
name or like the underwater superhero
so
uh yeah the comedians
uh i'm
been wondering about that too i thought
she was gonna do it last time because
she put the you know like the face mask
on
so
you kids gotta stop acting like us that
would be funny
that's funny it's funny
yeah i uh
i'm i'm curious about uh king uh what
kind of forever as well cole i
i don't know the direction they're going
to take so
there's
there's
there's a few directions i can think
that would work and some that i think
wouldn't work and i'm worried that they
might go down that route but i mean it's
marvel i've you know fifth marvel life
trust and more hey david henry bennett
thanks for that super chat uh i'll keep
you in mind for sure
um
if i
if i do decide to do it and hopefully i
do one day i would definitely kind of
like talk about it and say i have like
uh open
what are they called casting calls
vader or iron man
excuse me uh vader
i think vader would just force pull him
in and cut him in half
uh sue cats are actually rockets right
rocket is right there sleeping
hi
what you doing
hi
you wanna say hi to everybody
you didn't like it last time no you
didn't like to say hi last time but
let's say hi
what's up
you're crushing my cord
you're okay
say hey
[Music]
i have so much cat hair on me
uh definitely not talking any spoilers
for thor eleven thunder guys so for
those asking me like oh just people die
blah
we're not we're not doing that sorry
we can't do that um
although i get like the embargo is
lifted on the on the reviews and i can
do a spoiler review
um which i guess means i can but i'm
just i'm not gonna obviously
talk any spoilers here
i know that's not what you're doing but
uh
so secret war is madame webb the
beyonder
i don't know about madame webb
that's a sony thing
and who knows what they're doing that
um current thoughts on miss marvel
it's okay
there's some really cool parts to it but
so far it's just kind of okay
i'm not blown away
but also at the same time like
if it ends strong it could be a really
good series it all depends on how it
ends right i mean a bad ending could
make something that's okay really bad
you know
uh
and it or just
make something that's
you know okay
terrible
um
like a good show can be ruined by
a bad ending right a great show could
become a good show a good show can
become an occasion an okay show can
become a terrible show
uh so
it depends depends yeah no spoilers in
the chats guys uh i know thor
four is out in korea right now um
and probably a little a few other places
no spoilers guys or if you've read leaks
online or something like that
um
this is very different than a video
where we're talking about spoilers this
is a watch party about miss marvel so no
thor spoilers please uh we have three
minutes
um
i'm gonna use the bathroom
um but i'll answer a few questions two
geeks six episodes yes there are only
six
iran or aaron i think captain marvel is
gonna be miss marvel i think she's gonna
be in the post-credits scene for episode
6
and doom i think is coming
uh
i used to think at the in what kind of
forever but now i think a few projects
after that so
uh oh thank you kashav thank you thank
you very much i'm glad you like my cover
thank you thank you thank you
um
so yeah i'm going to use the bathroom
i'll be right back and then we'll start
oh this is my stream now
i'll just have to run this walnut
we back
oh happy thanks for the super chat can't
wait for thor have a great stream keep
up the good work thank you so much i
hope you love thor i loved it um
it's fantastic
i if you caught my review today you know
how i feel about it i i had
i i had a little some qualms about a
couple scenes
but i'm not sure other people will have
the same qualms
some people might think it's funny some
people might think
you know
whatever
but
some of some parts i thought could have
went in a different direction
so would i rather be a villain or a
superhero
superhero you're out
no episode 5's though you're out
all right we're going to start mission
marvel
episode five i need to get a stopwatch
up
go to the google a
stopwatch
mr anderson we're gonna start at five
four
three
two
one slayer
did i do it right aj did i do a good job
spectacular
kill tacular
okay goodbye
all right here we go
oh i stopped it no no no no
trail of stars she's gonna make the
trailer sorry she has to right
uh flying fox yeah i think i think it
might actually activate some that have
ned used it he's clearly got some magic
stuff
no
justice for waleed
all right this is where we ended clearly
that's like a rift in
something now she's
in partition
here we go
it has started
interesting
okay it's like we're like
okay we're def oh
huh
jeez
gandhi
british occupied india oh we're gonna
we're gonna see it here i think okay
here we go here we go
happy birthday
oh this is picking up where we left off
before
nerd
oh
cricket
i love cricket it's so much fun and it's
also really fun to watch
candy
day
i wonder if that's her great
grandfather
yeah uk and india are really great
cricket
that's awesome jj
you're at the rate please
it's already broken
no no i've never watched handball before
two went nice
mark that's funny think he's hot
i hope it's her i hope that's her great
grandmother actually that'd be cool
not much is really happening right now
we're just watching her great
grandmother
um
oh she's not a human though
haha
interesting
louis those are very high expectations
but but
she just get rockets just getting comfy
what you doing
getting comfy
i'm from a different dimension
so
bro this has i really hope this is her
grandpa father dude he's such a great
grandfather such a smooth talker
that's her name
nice
nice aries enjoy your vacation
yeah that's gonna be her grandfather
so this is maybe her first arriving at
the country or another country of the
world because she's you know from a
different dimension so
what's up john ponce what's going on
ah
and now they're together
and making a daughter
yeah i called it right there boom
all right this is a good couple i like
it i like both these peoples
both these people
then there's her grandmother
nanaisha
is her great grandmother
what up ricky
look at that little
baby
oh and now she's playing with the bangle
hmm
look at her play with that bangle
i'm kind of confused because clearly
like her grandmother and her mother know
something's up with the bengal
and if they know what it does shouldn't
they know that it was her great
grandmother that made the trail of stars
or kamala you know who knows
you
hmm
uh yes mass gamer i definitely think
there will be another avengers movie
i mean i really hope secret wars is
avengers secret wars
uh oh what is happening
well british soldiers
or
british soul juror
no
no
can't really say
oh it's that girl
oh
she don't want to go back now she's got
a baby
liar
you have until sundown tomorrow and
hey pp and jen what's up
hey torn what's going on hey
thank you for liking the channel let's
not spam in the chat though please
i think it'll do really good at the box
office but let's let's don't spam please
hmm
what's up arc
fortnite pokemon fan
uh she'll be in captain marvel 2 the
marvels
she'll be there
wait a second whoa hold the phone
it has to be kamala because
if
kamala's grandmother had the bengal and
not her great-grandmother then she had
the bengal when she was lost
which means it has to become all that
makes it right
hey thank you justin
you're right i am
dang he's too good
dang
hmm
this really should have been like the
last half of the last episode i'm
worried for this episode
although i do kind of like
knowing this story
hey it was there bar mayor thank you so
much for that super chat appreciate it
uh yeah brian i hope we do one day
sauna is the name of one of my favorite
kpop idols
i really hate this woman i hate najma
oh
she stabbed her just right away
all right this girl better die in this
episode or in in this uh
in this series najma better die
najma needs to die
title of this episode time and again
which makes me believe it really is
kamala who
you
oh
it's definitely going to be kamala
yeah right marcus yeah she woke up with
just violence
oh she enchanted it like
like mjolnir
interesting
oh
oh that's what she's been doing
i knew it
dang didn't want her to die
that's a
bummer knew it was kamala though
so that's what's been happening this
whole entire time she's been calling to
her
interesting
okay i could dig it i can dig that she
used the bangle to kind of call to her
it's kind of crazy that she
kind of gets to uh live through
live through partition
you know she's generations after it
happened
no one notices that
no one notices that
i guess it's a really important time and
everything
oh nice
oh that's cool
nice
so
why
why was her
great-grandmother viewed as somebody who
was so bad i don't understand there's
something about something's about to go
down right here
why was her grandmother
you have
oh
it's tearing into her world
uh
i thought
i thought i was about the episode was
about to end i was gonna be like come on
[Laughter]
the dog
hahaha
i don't i don't i don't think that's how
it works i think the veil is kind of
angry
hey thanks sinks
uh i'm not chris though i'm warren
not anymore
huh
she wants to go home
with the bangle
oh
whoa interesting
hmm
day
dang that's pretty cool
the bengal
right mr anderson
what is she doing oh she jumped up
all right something has to happen big
right now because we need a villain
dio
dc
coming in and
this feels like a final episode
so what's about to happen
oh
there it is there's a scarf
there's okay so it's going to be the
last
last uh
episode
her mom find
something oh that's how she's gonna get
her
they're they're getting uh
they're like moving on from this like
pretty quickly
springfield
bon jovi
wait so why was the grandma bad they
never
what
you
and they're just back now
and then the dodc is going to grab
comrade or not cameron
oh
oh
it's not brian
we don't talk about him
huh
took
his arms broke
who takes care of bruno
oh dang
oh come on that's the
please re oh my gosh please reveal
something
post credit post credit post credit post
okay
okay
wait editing
what editing
i didn't like that
oh man
that was that was bad ending
that was not a good ending
the first part of this episode should
have been the last part of the last
episode
that's
i mean so to me
i'm like
you're building up najma
and the clandestines to be like these
bad people
right they're the villains
they're they're trying to get
back home
and and once they're home
they're gonna take over this realm
and that's the threat
and now they're gone now they're just
out of the picture
and now the dod sees the villains
why
i mean
uh maybe it'll pay off
uh
not i i didn't i didn't like that i
didn't like that i didn't like that
i don't really know how i feel about the
episode um
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about this episode
i liked learning the story i'm glad we
find out
uh i'm glad we found out that it was her
that did the trail of stars like i
figured that we talked about that last
time we talked about
this time before the stream ended um
yeah see right it's a little bit okay
but here like
i have issues because
why did her
mother
go leave like why did her mother
say that and correct me if i'm wrong
mr anderson
let me let me know what you think
chat let me know what you think correct
me if i'm wrong her mother said
that kamala's great grandmother brought
shame to her family and she was the
reason she had to move across the world
am i wrong
i think i'm right i believe that's what
she said i will go back and check the
other episodes
but if so why
are they not going to answer that they
didn't show us anything about her mother
doing
anything bad at all like anything bad at
all
like in all the illuminati's talking
about how she killed somebody during
partition and stuff like that like
she was the one who died
she got killed
what is happening
where did that story
just dissolve
right because that's what it feels like
it just dissolved it's not there anymore
and then we have the clandestines who
are supposed to be the villains and all
of a sudden they're dead
unless they're really not
but it seems like they are we saw their
skeletons
hi i hated that i think yeah i think i i
can't defend it so okay hear me out hear
me out hear me out
but i agree but go ahead where
did the story go about her great
grandmother
being
a disgrace to the family and bringing
shame on their family and blah blah blah
blah that's like completely gone now
right you know what i mean like
well not even that like why was there
anybody even saying that
it doesn't make sense like what did she
do to be that's what i'm saying but that
wasn't even like that it didn't even
the
they they completely ignored it they
completely ignored it
she did nothing disgraceful she got
stabbed and separated from her family
that's the end of it her husband doesn't
even know what happened
right and
the trail of stars things was explained
but we all guessed that already so we
spent 30 minutes and teagan you know
teague over here says sums it up pretty
well
uh let me find what he said exactly so
the whole episode is about a character
that we don't really care about we don't
know her and we have no connection to
her and then they've expected us to feel
sad for her when she dies and it's true
it's like
why was that not a five-minute thing
where it's like oh she had a kid and
yeah it was actually her doing the trail
of stars and then we could get
30 minutes of actual explanation well
then we get 10 minutes of nothing but
confusion well this is what i said after
like the first part of this episode
ended i was like that should have been
the ending of episode four
yeah
because episode four
well half of it was unnecessary so they
could have put the first half of this
into that ended it with that and then
start off with the
half of this also the clandestines are
just gone now is that like
and cameron has powers and cameron has
powers and
and portal
and um
and now the drdc is the the villains now
like they completely like they had it's
like they had the story and then they're
like abandon it like just abandon that
story and this is what we're gonna do
yeah cause now there's like no bad guy
presumably because all the bad guys are
right well like time out real quick if
you guys like the episode that i'm not
bashing on people who liked it oh
absolutely i'm really glad that you
liked it if you liked it i just have
i have a problem with the writing i have
i don't have a problem with like what i
saw like visually it was cool but i have
a problem with the writing
granted i don't yeah no i like him on as
miss marvel i like the character really
really good she's great
i could use more miss marvel
stuff like powers being shown
i think that this is a example and one
of the first and best examples we've had
of disney plus potentially ruining a
project this would have been a really
good two hour movie i yeah yeah and and
i i
i don't know how the end what the end's
gonna be we have one more episode
but
this would have been a really good
two-hour movie cut a lot of the extra
stuff out get to the origin part story
maybe start with the train at the
beginning of the movie show that whole
thing and the trail stars and then you
don't have to go back and explain it
halfway in the middle
and then maybe you're right some of this
writing here unless there's some type of
hidden secret that we don't know which
we might not yet right right that's the
thing yeah episode six could
pull it all together i'm optimistic i'm
always gonna be but it is rough right
now yeah i'm i'm cur i
i'm optimistic because i don't think
yeah here's a here's a chat right here
uh fly guy tone i was just gonna say
this he says but kevin feige knows what
he's doing he'll recover it
uh
yes i have faith in kevin feige
but sometimes when you're working on a
project and you film things
you can change your mind about
everything my camera's blur you can
change your mind about everything
and it just doesn't come together
because you have a timeline and you have
x amount of dollars to put towards the
projects and things can go wrong
now we haven't heard anything about that
but like
i don't know um i'm pretty disappointed
i because i because i actually do really
like miss marvel
i think miss marvel be a lot of fun and
if anything you know you talk we we
talked about this in your podcast this
week you know you go back and you look
at phase one two three of the mcu they
were bad projects you know thor won
world war ii there's stuff that people
didn't like but that didn't ruin thor
like when thor showed up in the avengers
he was still good so when miss marvel
shows up in the young avengers or
wherever
you know we'll have this character now
and her not so great origin story and
hopefully
marvel can do what marvel does and move
forward from that we'll be fine you know
if you want to look big picture it's not
the end of the world but as far as this
series goes so far we're headed towards
a pretty massive disappointment i think
yeah uh to him i am two i thought it was
i thought it was i actually i think the
best episode so far is the first episode
the first one and then the wedding one
was pretty cool the wedding one was good
episode three was pretty good um but
like
it's gone downhill
it's definitely gone downhill episode
four wasn't that good this episode
wasn't good
but i
i i hope
it can end strong
yeah i do too
i don't think the character is
completely ruined for the future of the
mcu but this specific project
it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting i mean you
truly can't defend
how much that episode didn't mix with
the rest of the series
uh
well to me
it just
completely changed everything
like because they made
they made it about
certain things
yeah and then derailed from those things
it doesn't mix
and i'm like
that's
that's okay in episode three it's like
not episode five
you know what i mean uh which you spent
most of wasting our time and then very
very vaguely explaining what happened
and then done
i it's what's really weird is i actually
liked learning the backstory it just
shouldn't have been here
it was uh it was misplaced exactly it
was misplaced it should have started
with that right i it should have no it
should have been the ending of the last
episode
or that either way yeah so that we can
just get on with it for these last two
episodes
yeah
they could have cut
a lot of the
the extra part for this episode and a
lot of the extra parts for the last
episode right together well see here's a
good example nick it's nick
he just asked who's the bad guy in the
show now
this this bruno we don't talk about
bernie
bruno was the secret bad guy the whole
time he's actually kang it was bruce you
know all along
uh lewisbury thanks for super chat
better than the last one but
you hope oh the finale is sick i thought
i thought that said suck i was like you
hope the finale sucks uh point i hope
it's terrible
it's terrible
kelvin thanks kelvin our zoo thank
daredevil never had me like this oh
i
um
we're gonna do a poll because i'm just
curious
uh
not a single person in my channel
you
like
uh should we do do you like miss marvel
or did you like this episode
this episode
a lot of people like throughout and
towards the end like yeah they lost me
like they they lost me i'm seeing a lot
of that i'm seeing a lot of that
i actually haven't had a single person
say like that was an awesome episode
i've seen a few peop i've seen a few
people say
if you guys feel that way that may have
connected with you in a specific way but
my issue isn't the show or the character
no it's the right it's actually the
writing
the flow of the series right yeah i i
that's kind of my issue so far
lewis barry i saw you say that before
thanks for the super chat um i don't
think we're gonna see black boulder
spidey
uh or matt murr
you say mad i'm assuming it's matt
murdock i don't even see matt but carol
and monica maybe i definitely think
we're seeing carol in a post
credit scene
jake said 10 out of 10 great episode but
i think he's just being a dick
maybe he's not maybe he's not uh mr
anderson that's that's a see another
question by mr anderson what possessed
cameron or was it just new powers coming
to him it was definitely his mom giving
him but it's like
his mom never showed any signs of powers
right am i am i mistaken what's up
ritwick
and and what about her just bestows
powers on somebody across the planet
right she doesn't have the bengal the
bangle supposed to be the big key and
the secret and all of a sudden she could
just get her existence into cameron like
did she take did she take did she take
the power as she was dying and and take
some of the power from her old world and
give it to him maybe maybe that that was
just i'm just thinking off top of my
head i mean it's not it's the best
explosion i've got so far there's
nothing else she took some powers
i gotcha got him yeah so like
maybe
maybe as she's like getting killed
because i was like maybe they didn't die
maybe they maybe they actually did go to
that university but we saw their
skeletons so yeah
uh hold on to him
to him the member of the channel what uh
i have faith in kevin feige but like
after hawkeye this says let me down
honestly anyone who likes haku i find
but [ __ ] was mid
yeah
i i i
i have
i fainted kevin feige i'm holding to it
but i don't know but this is hard
the problem is if you're gonna make a
series you can't just make the ending
good like this episode and the last
episode they weren't good like if you're
gonna want to go back and re-watch a
marvel project
i won't i won't re-watch the yeah i i
and that's because of the writing so
even if at the ending they like make it
they explain it it's really good and all
it's like yeah but it's just it doesn't
mix it's weird this is like eating
kind of corn flakes and
something that doesn't go with corn
flakes like it's just it's a terrible
thing i'm tired but you know it just
doesn't work right now and i think
that's not even something that's
necessarily salvageable the overall
experience with a really good ending is
savage salvageable but the flow of the
the series is gone
yeah the flow was not good in this one
[Music]
and like and like
i feel like
the problem is is like shows progress
and
this one hasn't well
it's egressed it's it was like trying to
build up to
this whole big thing about partitioning
the grandmother and the story
and and and
the clandestines they've been you know
the bad guys they've been attacking and
and even even it showed najma killing
uh her great-great-grandmother or
great-grandmother um
and that's like all the progression and
now it's like
done
like
it's it's got like all gone it's gone it
didn't really
it didn't really lead anywhere
like it gave us it feels like everything
was kind of just leading to like
they were relying on this big moment
where it was like oh this huge story
about their whole family during
partition and the grandmother was led by
the stars oh we can't explain it oh it
was kamala the entire time
which is cool but not big enough
right we knew it we figured this out
yeah
it's like
zcy9951 says the disappointment on your
face and probably more than half of it i
mean
i don't have and and this is the first
time i can't really project
this is the first time
including hawkeye falcon of the winter
soldier all of them that i have
literally been like
this is
this is bad
i still like this more than what it is
yeah but what if it doesn't really it
doesn't count yeah i mean it's content
for disney plus and really that's how i
look at it it does explain i guess
multiverse stuff and the beyonder will
be the same character and the same actor
probably if he ever shows up in the mcu
but as far as like
pushing forward the story of the current
mcu status this one's supposed to be
great pretty important you know marvel's
coming up this has some real immediate
connections and stuff
and it's just not been told that well
unfortunately and i think the biggest
problem is they tried to make a series
out of a movie and this should have just
been a movie
you could probably agree with that i
needed to change some story stuff
apparently yeah i i can agree with you
on that um two interesting comments here
sue i think it failed to focus on
something yes
yeah we don't have a bad guy and
whatever it was focusing on is actually
gone now
yeah so
it was focusing on right we've lost
tahin
says yes i'm indian but you can't
completely rely on on the history of
what this two countries share and has
nothing to do with the story progression
yeah because i it's like it it's there's
no progression anymore andy is mcu
official
oh i know right gandhi
uh
cool oh
louis thanks for another super chat cool
cliffhanger and flashbacks but rest rush
i actually didn't like the cliffhanger
because it was super rushed it was like
the actual part where she was there
lasted 20 seconds
i'm hoping it's like aim
is actually
like behind the dodc i think i mean that
would be cool but i don't think we'll
get that answer in this series
i feel like that's like an armor wars
thing
sue thank you for that super chat things
just got out of hand
uh things just
left the hands it's like
i yeah like i would i would love if
things got out of hand i feel like
please
feel bad for bruno get ryan get out of
here stop
bringing brian
he's like i genuinely thought your name
was brian
imagine touching your doorway home and
then just getting demolished
yeah like it was it was
i guess the bengal did open up the
doorway but uh
maybe they did need to to open it up huh
maybe that was a problem
because remember and whatever episode it
was they said uh the guy said there
would be two bengals and they're like oh
one will have to do
but uh maybe they did need to
maybe that's why it killed them maybe
they did need to and asia hinted at one
point
that the bengal won't work
and that was the entirety of it like
she's supposed to explain to us at this
point why the bengal wasn't gonna work
and then she was supposed to tell her no
it will work and then they fight she's
like no the bengal won't work and that
was it
yeah that's the part where you're
supposed to say
some history about the bengal and like
it comes from this place and it's the
nega band and it's from this thing right
or explain something or give us some
type of reveal
these
theories
you know we're told have this important
weight and how you have to watch them to
know what's going on in the mcu and
that's still true
sure
the whole theme of them has been
oh you know they're about them like
there's not these big cameos or reveals
but like why not
yeah
why can't we get
at least sometimes
why hasn't captain marvel been in
episode five and six why don't we get
big reveals no why can't moon knight
name drop something crazy i feel like
maybe to some extent these these disney
plus shows are gonna have to start
giving us some movie level information
and reveals or people are gonna stop
caring
yeah
i yeah i think so
i
yeah i mean
justin stanton thanks for super chat the
only thing that can save this show
is more bs it's morbid time
rate the show so far what will episode
six be it's like a five
um
and struggling past yeah
oh
of artist for doctor strange in idiot
what in india oh never mind yeah sorry
what just said that
molo's dad is the audio artist for
doctor strange in india so fun fact oh
interesting uh lewis berry i think black
bolt could appear to help out with
spidey there
at the same time zoe's going to really
need a good lawyer
matt monica and carol diane i mean
separately yes but i don't i wouldn't
expect to see black bolt in this show
and it's not showing up yeah in a
different show yeah
uh danny bellow yes thanks for super
chat there's one more
uh there's one more episode
and i hope here's the thing i hope it i
just i hope it
i hope it plays out actually the poll
right now says 54 like the episode 46
percent did it interesting
what are you gonna say that's going to
represent the majority of people's
feelings
but maybe i don't know i mean i think
the issue is it's not really an argument
about whether ms marvel's good it's just
bad
writing you can't really argue that it
isn't i mean just basic based off of
what you said when i first got in here
like why is she some disgrace and some
dishonorable nothing happened that made
her just disgraceful
yeah and then there's no bad guys like i
guess something could change that it all
will make sense now her mom's just super
supportive and it's just all these
radical changes in the span of 20
minutes just don't make any sense
whatsoever yeah and
that's what i don't like it's just they
change them
with any of the characters or the cgi
the effects the fight scenes like it's
all really cool and i'm excited to see
ms marvel in the future i just think her
series is
it's kind of rough it's yeah there's a
question here um
derek dabo i'm confused why does time
travel work differently in this episode
than time travel and end game how to
achieve in time travel so easy
explanation time travel in-game was more
science this is magic
and mr anderson even said like um
he liked how she enchanted
the the bengal right which that was cool
it's almost like thor's hammer right um
but
i don't know they kind of lost me louis
berry thanks for another one
three is still the best yet red daggers
yeah i really like that episode the what
the wedding and everything you know
yeah but uh
[Music]
uh they wasted too much time in the
beginning even though the story was
important and i was curious about the
story i think it was
that should have been episode four
and
yeah episodes one two three we're really
good i agree and then these two episodes
kind of haven't helped out they're gonna
need something pretty spectacular to
happen the next one i think to turn it
around but even then
there are gonna be some big question
marks i think on what
made sense and what didn't in this
series and what i was gonna say yeah
it it worries me
they're independent projects and they're
different but just this nonstop trend of
nothing significant happening in the
shows worries me a little bit for
she-hulk i think something that she-hulk
really is gonna need
are gonna be some of these major
connections i mean you have hulk in this
series right one of the og avengers
yeah i mean and we're hoping for you
know there's this whole idea from what
we've seen in trailers and a few of the
different stuff we've read
like there's this big huge legal thing
going on with superheroes and there's
this whole new facility and you know
you need to have some stuff
of substance pushing the narrative of
the mcu forward here and you know you
did a video what three days ago now
where you talk about ben grimm showing
up like i'm not even showing about that
nessa's talk about that necessarily like
that would be super super cool yeah but
like what's going on in the mcu right
now we have a
literal celestial's arm reaching out of
somewhere right that's a bit that's a
big thing right that's a big thing
like all of this stuff that's just
floating around and i don't know why i
feel like she she-hulk has to address it
at least a little bit at some point
you have an avenger in your series you
have one of the og avengers one of
arguably the strongest characters in
marvel history in your series who
literally time traveled
like
there has to be something addressed yeah
or these series are just going to lose
more and more audience members i just
and i get why they need them i get the
business aspect of it like hey let's do
these marvel plus series because people
will pay for disney plus but you gotta
give us something
yeah and i think it goes back to
telling longer stories of origins like
being able to origin stories and making
them longer but i agree with you this
could have been a movie instead should
have been a movie it should have been a
movie uh hold on real quick mark ginaway
hey thank you so much for that super
chat i really appreciate it hey man
never caught any of your lives till
today sorry about that family man no
worries these are really late and if you
have a family i got you uh appreciate it
for everything you do thank you so much
i really i really appreciate that i do
i'm glad you could uh catch a live
stream here i hope you enjoy it reed
bowens second best mcu disney plush show
so far hey i'm really glad you're loving
it man
i am like i i always say like my opinion
great if we all agree on it if not it's
okay
if you're liking the show i'm glad
you're liking the show i wish i could be
really really into the show and think
it's a really great show right now um
i let up miss marvel
the character i think no she's fantastic
i'm really happy she's gonna be in the
marvels
i actually think
miss marvel iman is going to make the
marvels better i a thousand percent
agree i just think they messed up her
show yeah i don't think they did good
we'll see how it ends but well that's
two different things right there's oh
wow this show is really bad and oh wow
this character is terrible no the
character is not bad at all like great
didn't dislike miss marvel because the
story wasn't good they didn't like miss
marvel because they didn't really like
bri larson and i guess it's a blanket
statement some people really do like but
it was the attitude of brie larson i
think for the majority of fans that were
kind of like yeah wow this wasn't so
great the actual movie itself was pretty
good like the story the writing the
whole oh nick fury lost his eye this
thing that thing the explanation
this is the reverse problem like
she's awesome she's fantastic her show's
not that great yeah
louis barry thanks for super jazz
exactly what you're just saying miss you
know amanda's carrying the show she's
cute talented
she's fantastic yeah hey big super chat
suffering in college thanks so much
the show really feels like two seasons
got condensed into one it's jarring
two from episode one two three to this
pakistan slash time travel story back to
jersey with no villains in abusive six
yeah i mean
it it's it's like rushed for some reason
but they did that to themselves by
completely
derailing from the story that has been
built up so far
like i think there are so many cool
parts
of this series they're just not like
arranged in the right order
yeah
and maybe they did some big chop and
block and switch some stuff around
because
something wasn't right and they had to
fix it but
maybe lewis barry watch bcs if you
haven't it's on breaking bad level bcs
let's look at that
um
the other thing and i guess this is a
problem for the future and hopefully
maybe will be addressed
presumably what's the next project we
see miss marvel in
i think just the marvels
but
so do you think we're going to get brie
larson in the next episode i i stand by
what i've been saying from the beginning
i think i've said
before the first episode even aired
i think
captain marvel shows up at the post
credits scene for episode six okay i
think i agree with you on that just
because what is she gonna come to fight
the the dodc or whatever like no she's
not
but um what's the connection other than
the fact that miss marvel
idolizes captain marvel yeah they're not
the same there's no
their story the origin they're they're
they're race they're kind they're not
race like human race like alien race
i don't get
they're just gonna throw her in with
maria or monica and it's like
a team now because she likes captain
marvel i just i don't know well i
actually think that
uh
let me
uh
go deeper into this here i don't think
i don't think uh miss i don't think miss
marvel and captain marvel are going to
interact i think it's going to be like
captain marvel's on like a ship
somewhere and she gets like a reading
for something
because she's not planning i think
that would explain how they're coming
together then maybe yeah because i mean
if shang cheese is off planet right
right uh that could make more that would
be fine i'd be all right with that but
if it's just like hey you love me and
you're a superhero let's work together
that's just no it's gonna it's gonna be
related
it has to be related to the bengal
because she's she you know
thought she was cree she knows the cree
the bengal is cree
there's going to be it's going to be
like chongqi like
the ring sent off the signal
and blah blah blah blah blah it's gonna
be same with the bangle the bengals sent
off a signal
carol picked it up
the same thing is the the
rings with the bengals the same
technology and it's gonna be something
like that yeah
and then we'll start seeing these major
connections and i think we're definitely
getting there and i'm not worried about
the connections i don't need the
connections to enjoy everything i
obviously want them to happen and when
they do they're going to be epic
yeah i just think we do need something
pushing a narrative at some point here
yeah
yeah that's that's what i think a lot of
fans are getting
impatient and that's gonna put so much
weight on she-hulk and i just don't know
if they're gonna do it because what
she-hulk's gonna be about she-hulk
right just like every other project
we've gone and there's a lot of pressure
going to be put on this series that and
that's because the hulk is there because
they're showing us this jail with all
sorts of superheroes in it and it is
kind of got this whole legal aspect of
the mcu happening
it's gonna be a lot of weight yeah
we'll see
david did you not feel that do you not
feel like you would expect that weight
because i kind of i don't expect it no
well not expect like them to do it but
expect like you would like them to do it
like i would like to be more
i don't know i would like us to know
more about what is going on in the
universe as a whole because all the
projects that they've released
separately
have not given us a
good complete picture of the mcu
and kevin feige did say we're going to
be getting some of those soon yeah we'll
see i'm ready
i'm ready for them yeah i want some of
these connections because that's when
you know this is when the fun begins
yeah you know i'm going to start kind of
piecing everything together like the
massive puzzle it is yeah and i don't
doubt that there are these connections
out there i'm just ready for them now
yeah david henry bennett i am thinking
we get a carol on america cameo thanks
for super chat uh carol would make a lot
of sense america chavez
i don't know maybe because of that whole
different realms thing and stuff like
that
love to see louis barry another one
thank you i'm liking the show about this
episode
the last episode were the worst ones i
agree
yeah yeah they just dropped all this
weird multiple dimensions and one plane
knowledge on us and that's not gonna get
touched again is it
what was it
the whole
last episode when they're like yeah so
earth has like six seven eight different
dimensions living on top of it oh the
weird map i don't think we're gonna
that's not good i don't think that's
gonna be addressed in the next episode
no but it was supposedly like important
information and now it's like yeah
here's a light and they're all dead and
move on it's like this well that's
that's that's my issue is they built
they built up
the clandestines and and it was really
really weird like
they they haven't like
really even told us much about where
they're from in all honesty we don't
know anything about where they're from
um
and
there's a lot there's there's here's the
day you want to talk about putting
weight on something there's a lot of
weight in the next episode
like i i don't even know if there's
anything the next episode can do
i that's what i'm sitting here thinking
what can you do in the next episode
that's gonna make me go
this finished well
because i don't think ever said four and
five were done well
right all they really need to do at this
point
is save miss marvel like they need to
preserve her character make sure iman
goes out really well
so that we can move on but in my mind i
mean they'd have to do something pretty
special and
and easily explained
for this series to be like oh yeah no
that actually was all really great it
turns out because they've abandoned so
many different things that they've
brought up briefly right that's why
that's why it's time to explain it all
in exactly that's what i think was kind
of bad writing but
uh reid bowen's over thank you for that
super chat overall do i think that mg
has fallen off no because
i explained this in my video the other
day
we're used to getting two
three movies a year now we have three to
four movies a year and a lot of disney
plus shows it's like they're not you
know i don't think they're all going to
knock it out of the park um and they
don't have to and miss marvel's great at
introducing miss marvel iman like
it's we do learn her story
like we've now have her origin story and
she's you know there's they stick true
to like you know
her loving carol danvers and all that
and being a big you know like uh
avengers nerd like we all are and stuff
like that there's there's great things
to this show
i just think the writing's not that
great
now i will say if they turn around and
you mentioned this now and they
they
reveal that the dodc this aim is aim or
it's a bunch of scrolls
the powers of the earth or something
like that
would redeem everything
because yeah okay they cut off all the
the story of all this stuff the origin
of miss marvel
because this is where ms marvel came
from where this is where the bengal came
from this is her family and her story
and yeah they didn't really give it an
ending but they cut it off it's ended
and now let's find out that the dodc is
actually
aim or skrull trying to get all the
technology of earth so that they can do
secret invasion something like that
not that i believe that will happen but
something like that would actually be
epic
yeah
i and that would even stop to be done
right
i mean it would have to be done
very right yeah but that is really the
only direction i think that they can go
to salvage the entirety of this series
maybe
who knows maybe they have something
crazy planned
and and to go back to your question reid
uh you know i've seen thor
and thor's fantastic love and thunder
so you know what i mean and uh
i liked multiverse of madness i know
some people didn't i love chongqi i
enjoyed the internals um
i think back to phase one and not
everything was a banger you know what i
mean it it it felt like it because it
was so new and it's really exciting i
will say avengers 1 is a banger
iron man yeah america i mean there's
films
yeah there's a lot of it but you know
not everything in
phase one phase two phase three was
amazing you know so it's like i'm not i
don't think mc's falling off
but i think they're you know sometimes
in these disney plush shows they miss
with some things you know
um and again i
i really really like the character
they've introduced i just i agree the
progression of
the series as a whole i'm not a fan of
how they're doing it i'm not a fan of
the writing and stuff like that um
so i mean that's just all i'm kind of
thinking about right now i'm finally
getting
i'm finally getting the naked
messages best adult dating
i'm a real live streamer now are you
really are you streaming enough if
you're not getting those ads
uh the sex spots oh gosh sorry chat yeah
yeah so no i
you know we had i did this whole video
with chris that we released when i don't
know whenever we released it sunday or
something uh
i don't think the mc has fallen i i
don't either i'm ha i i
i'm not walking away saying phase four
sucks there's a lot of things i did
really like about it yeah i just uh i
think phase five needs to start bringing
things together
yeah i think we've been having kind of
all the the hors d'oeuvres and and the
appetizers here and now i'm ready for
the steak
yeah right that's eating our vegetables
then you get to get the steak yeah
derek debbie makes a good point 71 for
thor four round tomatoes but miss marvel
has a 98
it started off strong i think that
number will drop
i think that 98 percent is for iman
i think it's four minutes first three
episodes were fantastic i loved those
yeah it was a lot more in it in the
first three episodes yeah i think a lot
of people were saying and i yeah
it's gonna be my favorite series and
then
it's fall it fell off yeah i i think it
fell off and see i was gonna say like i
i could have even
i could have dealt with episode four if
we got a good fifth episode and it still
would it would have been a great series
and now i'm like
oh man so much is riding on this last
episode
for it to come off as a great series
where the first three episodes were
setting the series up to be a great
series and then ford dropped the ball
and i think this one dropped the ball
too
but
well we'll find out next week ladies and
gentlemen will goku be able to take all
of the dragon balls find out next
episode on dragon ball z
uh zek the zek um probably he says you
think disney is requiring a certain
amount of shows for disney plus content
i feel like marvel's overwhelmed by all
the work that's how you get mass shows
thanks for that super chat you never
know yeah maybe possible they like
signed up for a certain amount of shows
because you know disney owns them and
disney's like all right look here you go
this is what you're doing do this now
make make the content and all of a
sudden they go for making three movies a
year to making eight projects a year and
it's like whoa
actually more because we're getting like
four movies a year now like five to
three plus shows it's like
you know nine practices a year eight
nine ten projects a year that's a lot
you know
there most of truth to your comment
there
um
so yeah uh without spoilers what do i
think of the thor love and thunder
credit scenes i like them both
i i really did i did
all you guys need to know is first if
you
and then when you
and you take it and you put
and then at the very end when you
yeah so well sad well said
so yeah uh
better than doctor maybe it's maybe it's
scroll maybe it's aim maybe
it's something
uh whatever
i'm curious i'm curious to see what
episode 6 for holds for us in a week i
i'm curious to see what the finale is uh
how crazy would it be if it's like
they break into the dodc and they get
into the secret files and they pull open
a filing cabinet if that's even still a
thing anymore and they they pull out a
paper and it's like wait a minute the
dodc
is a
side brand of marketing of doom
corporation
well okay so that's the thing is like
the dodc is clearly something
i i would be shocked if they were just
like
a department of the united states
government and it's like i'll deal with
the superheroes ah you know what i mean
i would be shocked they clearly seem
evil
they've set up this new agent uh i can't
remember the woman's name but they've
set her up to kind of
be bad right she's kind of a douche
i mean she is right i mean she's doing
her job but she's you know
it's like the good cop bad cop thing and
she's the bad cop right and
they're setting it up to where she's not
where the dodc that is not her they're
not you know like good
so
there's something there hopefully it
pays off
but mr anderson like you said and like i
said
uh
since episode four missed i was hoping
this one would kind of like make up for
it but now there's so much writing on
episode six's shoulders the finale
shoulders and
i'm just i'm worried about it i i do
think they can pull it off
and hopefully they have good plans um
scroll
aim i mean something is coming right
exactly enough that it can connect to it
just depends if they actually do it and
that's the thing is
as far as our scoreboard goes for them
actually doing it whatever it is in
every series they haven't actually done
any of it yeah
like we're sitting here like well maybe
they will do this this and this like the
odds are they probably won't
unfortunately
yeah oh deever thank you
thanks for that uh hello jaden israel
diver agent dever
yeah i mean
but
i will be watching the sixth episode and
we'll have fun with it i mean yeah
obviously we're gonna finish it and uh
i've enjoyed watching iman play ms
marvel i i actually
would have liked it to just focus a
little bit more on
her
maybe
just have more of her like using her
powers and figuring stuff out and then
have this villain
there like the entire time i would have
written the story different but hey i'm
not a writer i'm a youtuber so what can
i really say
uh
yeah louis barry thanks for another
super chat let's stop the super chat
guys because we're gonna um end the
stream soon but love kamala and kate
will
want to see together i agree i would
like to see kamal and kate together and
we will the young avengers for sure
so all right everybody thanks for
stopping by the live stream tonight um i
do have hope and faith that miss marvel
and strong
uh and hey everybody go see thor love
and thunder this week because it's
awesome and i think a lot of people are
really gonna love it uh i i did i did so
thanks to chris for joining as usual
be honest it's two
it's past 2am
yeah it is um there's links in
the chat for chris's channel for mr
anderson's channel mr anderson thanks
for being a great mod
um
and if you like the live stream and
you're new you can subscribe if you want
to my channel
um we'll be back here next week and of
course we post videos every day but
sunday sometimes sundays but we try to
take those days off um
so yeah i mean 56 said they liked the
this episode i'm glad i'm good i uh i'm
glad
people like the episode i'm glad people
like seriously they're not hyper
critical yeah
honestly it's just good for the
community yeah and i'm like i'm not
harsh on writing often but that's my and
that's my issue with this series it's
hard to defend it is the problem yeah as
somebody who usually defends it it's
like oh no the cgi is not that bad oh
the writing's not a bad fact yeah
like it's hard to defend this one like
you're 100 right yeah so but we'll see
what happens next week i'm excited i'm
really really excited uh
so yeah hey thanks everybody
for stopping by thanks for the super
chats the regular chats and those who
just watch in the background here on
cosmic culture yeah
on cosmic wonder culture good night
everybody say goodbye to chris everyone
all right
thank you all the members who stopped by
i really appreciate you guys um
and yeah i'm gonna keep an open mind
and we'll see it next week we'll see
what happens but hey love you all and
every universe thank you so much for
joining the stream tonight to